good afternoon everyone we're gonna get
started again after our afternoon break
so please come on back in I have the
distinct pleasure this afternoon to
introduce a panel of very very
distinguished guests my name is Anna
Steve Caen I have met some of you before
during the course of today and the
associate director for innovation and
strategic partnerships with the Scott
Institute for energy innovation at
Carnegie Mellon quite a mouthful it's a
great job and an opportunity to meet all
of you so I work day in and day out to
bring together partnerships and and
create synergies where possibly they did
not exist before and so as a part of
that we have brought together this very
esteemed panel on public-private
partnerships activating city utility and
university engagement so today I welcome
to the stage grant urban who's the chief
resilience officer an assistant director
for the Department of City Planning city
of Pittsburgh at the far end he's our
moderator today so grant serves as the
chief resilience officer where he
oversees the integration of
sustainability and resilience into city
services programs and policy and is a
great partner to Carnegie Mellon
University Jason Anderson is in the
middle he's the president and CEO of
clean tech San Diego which is a
nonprofit organization for members which
includes more than 100 local businesses
universities government and nonprofits
committed to advancing sustainable
solutions for the benefit of the economy
in the environment as president and CEO
Jason manages manages and leads several
initiatives including smart cities San
Diego advocacy efforts and economic
development programs Phillip Macy is
further down in the middle he is the
president and CEO of Itron he is an
industry visionary working to drive
digital transformation in the utility
space during his tenure at Itron the
company has grown from a metering
technology provider to a leader in the
intern
of Things connecting smart devices to
manage to better manage resources Itron
is a leader in the energy and water
sectors and maisy helps drive the
dialogue around utilizing technology and
data to create more connected vibrant
efficient and safer utilities and cities
David Owens joins us as well
he is the retired executive vice
president of Edison Electric Institute
he's an accomplished executive with
extensive experience in public policies
surrounding utility operations strategic
planning technology development rate
making and regulation he retired from EE
I last year but he remains an adviser to
EE I and serves on the board of Xcel
Energy he also chairs the transformation
Advisory Council providing insights in
the new design of the Puerto Rico
electric systems from what I understand
he has hardly retired at all
and finally we have rich rios e
president and CEO of Duquesne Light
Company here in Pittsburgh he serves as
the president and chief executive
officer in Duquesne Light and Duquesne
Light Company and the holding companies
under realsies leadership the company
invested significant resources to ensure
that its infrastructure the wires
substation poles and other equipment
that make the company's transmission and
distribution system meets current and
future electric demands and with that
I'm going to turn it over to you grant
and our esteemed panel great thank you
Anna and thank you all for for joining
us here this afternoon for this really
great panel and thank you all gentlemen
for coming to Pittsburgh the three of
you and rich riches the he's the
hometown entertainment here so so it's
great to spend a you know spend an
afternoon with you guys and talking
about some really innovative things just
a little bit of context I guess for why
this panel and
and I have the pleasure of hosting a
class this semester here at Carnegie
Mellon on kind of exactly this topic
really looking at the issues of smart
cities and the integration of smart city
data and utilities and when we started
to conceptualize this I think one of the
things that really became one of the
hallmarks of the conversation was the
need for partnerships and the need for
dialogue and as I just you know kind of
look down the line and one of the things
is I've had the pleasure of meeting each
of these individuals and having kind of
an opportunity to share space and time
with them and either on different panels
or just using kind of your guidance in
some of the work that we are doing here
in the city of Pittsburgh and and it
really starts me off kind of the the
first question that I wanted to kind of
ask everyone is you know you're seeing a
lot of synergies right now in this space
between cities and utilities and
universities and and and the reason I
think is because there's there's big
challenges there out there that all of
our our respective sectors are
encountering whether it's issues of
climate change or managing product loss
or integrating technology into our
business platforms we're confronting the
same questions at the same time but
maybe starting with you Philip in terms
of kind of what you're seeing in terms
of you know Itron and kind of the work
that you guys do around the world kind
of nationally globally why are these
synergies occurring between universities
and private sector partners like
utilities and and cities like what is
the confluence and what's leading to
that well I mean for years people been
talking about the proliferation of
sensors and the proliferation of data
that's generated by those sensors what
we don't talk about as much as is that
there's a lot of work that needs to go
into building economical reliable
accurate sensing devices out in the
field so there's there's continued
research required in order to do that
how we connect those sensors back to the
home office how we operate those
networks and for goodness sake what do
we do with all the data that we're
collecting through these networks are
just these pressing problems where we're
sort of making it up as we go along
and and requires a lot of collaborative
work and collaborative thinking
particularly with universities building
these kinds of data at large data
networks and data analytics capability
requires significant investment and the
idea that there is a complete overlap
and in building infrastructure out
across municipalities primarily for us
water utilities electric and gas
utilities doesn't seem particularly
resourceful or practical to have this
sort of duplication and overlap so we
spend a lot of time working with
multiple stakeholders and in urban
environments really trying to explore
how it is that we can better share
Network resources and and collaborate
more effectively on driving more value
out of data which requires really this
kind of collaborative environment we're
talking about thank you you know from
San Diego's perspective and apology for
being the Californian in the room and
also the purveyor of fine sauce there
you go so from San Diego's perspective
you know we're a we're kind of the
coldest sac of California we're at the
bottom of the state were surrounded by
the ocean the desert in another country
and so for us your collaboration is
really just kind of built into our
culture it's just a way we do things in
San Diego and when clean tech San Diego
was launched 11 years ago it was really
that mindset around how do we bring the
academic universities institutions to
the table with the private sector the
public agencies and our one we have one
IOU San Diego Gas and Electric in our
region to really think about these kind
of solutions these problems from a
regional perspective where we all have
kind of a stake in the game for us and
we now start thinking about data and how
you know that this kind of collaboration
around data comes together I know
someone in the previous panel talked
about the the pilot project in Atlanta
around streetlights and sensors we're
doing the same thing in San Diego we've
got 3,400 sensors that are being
installed in our community on street
lights by current and AT&T and that's
pushing out an amazing amount of data
that again we have really no idea what
to do with but what everyone cares in
this collaboration is
economic development how are we creating
jobs how are you benefiting our local
economy what's the result to our local
environment or a global environment
and so all this data is turned into just
a really interesting set of tools that
app developers are using to develop
applications and those are creating jobs
and it's just this kind of interesting
kind of confluence of all these
different interested parties so for us
you know we're all coming together in
San Diego because we believe there are
significant climate opportunities cloud
challenges that we need to that we're
facing and we believe that technology
plays a significant role in addressing
those but there's a huge economic
opportunity for that as well so as we
really think about data and pushing data
out into the community the city of San
Diego has an open data portal it's
really about who's gonna take that data
and do what with it and create a next
you know the next economic engine for
San Diego let me respond let me respond
differently to the question an excellent
question I do agree with my colleagues
there responds let's take an example of
what's happening in the electric
industry so right now we have 75 million
Smart Meters that have been installed
throughout the utility systems in
America we have 220 million customers
that the private sector serves so
tremendous number of customers have
smart meters so smart meters have a mi
so that means that there's data that
comes from those smart meters that can
help that utility plan and understand
when a customer loses service some
customers particularly in San Diego and
other sunny areas have rooftop solar
those ripped-off Soler's have smart
inverters those smart inverters provide
a lot of information about the customers
behavior so does a smart meter some of
those customers in San Diego also have
electric vehicles those electric
vehicles have charging stations that
provide a lot of information all of
these technologies provide tremendous
data that could be very helpful to the
utility as it seeks to plan and operate
system universities a part of that
customer base that the utility serves so
one good example would be if I looked at
what's occurring and actually Phil is
doing it in Spokane Washington where
they're working with the universities
where the universities are taking the
viewpoint we have three objectives that
we want to accomplish much like the
utility has these same objectives we
want reliability we want efficiency or
affordability and we want to improve
sustainability so those are the three
areas that are driving a lot of the need
to collaborate and to use this data in a
very useful way right now the data is
very unstructured we get reams of data
as a utility but we don't structure that
data I haven't even spoken about
monitors and sensors that are throughout
the utility system as we begin to
convert our substation so those
substations are much smarter more
analytic and more data-driven so we're
moving into a society where technology
is producing data and we need to have a
way that we are able to structure that
data and make that data much more useful
that's why collaboration is essential so
I'll approach it a little bit
differently being a privately held
company we have investors that expect to
return on our investment and I think you
know we have to overcome some of the
business challenges and how did we
develop a sustainable model at the end
of the day I think you know this unique
time that we live in and these
partnerships that are coming together
are one being driven by a common vision
right that vision that we have to work
and live much more sustainably than we
have have in the past - I think you
heard some of the other earlier panel
speakers talk about the g2 accelerate
this we have some inertia ahead of us
because the economics aren't always
there so how do you overcome that
inertia the unique partnerships that
we're talking about I think afford us
the opportunity to do that so as we
think about smart cities we think that
they're underpinned by three pillars the
first pillar is you have to cost
effectively deploy all the sensors that
are out in the field to gather that data
the second pillar then is you have to
develop a communication network so you
can collect all that data and move it up
to the cloud the third pillar then is
that you have open access to that data
so that we can take the folks that have
the intellectual capability at the
universities that have a forward lean on
that technology and forward thinking
that develop the tools that we need so
that we can operate and take that data
and make effective economic use out of
it so having said that then when you
look at the partnerships that are
evolving between universities between
utilities between cities we all have
assets in the field the city is a big
consumer of some of the information that
will come out of this to help them
operate more efficiently as a utility
we're a platform operator so we have
lots of sensors in the field today we
have controls in the field to manage
you'll hear about that a little bit
later from some of the other panel
participants so we have that expertise
it's there we've developed communication
networks to gather all of that data so
as what said here you don't want to
replicate those investments over and
over you want to leverage the assets
between all the players that are at the
table so we need to leverage and
contribute our our infrastructure assets
and our knowledge to the table we
partner with the universities to tap
into that intellectual base we tap into
the city to interface with them and
provide you know products and services
to them as well so I want to jump right
off of one of the things that you just
said when you were talking about
leveraging assets because one of the
things that we've done with the class
this semester and many of the students
are here with us today so there I'm sure
going to be going to be listening very
carefully and intently hi is that we do
have an opportunity particularly in a
city that is rebuilding as we are or at
a point of infrastructure improvement
should really take that opportunity to
capitalize across utilities and so
that's really what we're thinking about
as a part of the class is how can we
actually create an ROI what makes sense
for each individual player within a city
to make those investments investments
and and
investigate that data together so that's
really sort of what we've been looking
at you know maybe to pick up and then I
was gonna ask you guys I'm gonna throw a
curveball at you and start with Anna you
know one of the things that we talked
about in preparing for this was you know
what are some of the hallmarks of a
strong partnership so that's the easy
question but like and I threw the class
and some of the things that we've
discovered what are some of the
challenges that we're seeing or that
you're experiencing in developing
partnerships what are some of the
pitfalls or some of the the the things
that we might not if we were just here
by ourselves say that we would talk to
and how do you overcome those challenges
in partnership building well an
interesting thing that we've talked
about is data because data is so
important for informed decision making
and yet access to some of that data for
a university partner can be challenging
there's so many privacy rules there's
PUC regulations etc so being able to
access that information to make those
decisions is it is a critically
important part and I'm just gonna use
that as my number one talking point I
totally agree with you and I think I
thought outstanding job this morning her
presentation and she made the point that
a utility traditionally is subject to
public policy and that public policy for
the most part is regulation so when
you're engaged in a partnership where
you are heavily regulated and may be
precluded from actually being a total
participant in a project and your
potential partner does not have that
regulatory overlay it creates a
different type of a relationship might
give them it get more exposed explicit
so for example and spoke to the notion
of a micro grid a micro grid is a mini
network which has a power supply source
and most of those power supply sources
today
or renewable technologies backed up with
batteries well a utility if you're in at
what we call an organized market if
you're in the Pennsylvania New Jersey
Maryland interconnection or in New York
or in California and in other states
you are precluded from owning power
supply you were told to diverse a power
supply to create a competitive mark
now if you're trying to be a partner
with someone who wants to build a micro
grin you have the balance sheet that can
sustain building that micro grid and you
want to keep that customer and
demonstrate to that customer your
commitment to resiliency you are
precluded for the level of participation
you can have in a micro grid and I know
that as a fact because I've testified in
many of these proceedings so what we
need to do is extend that partnership in
a way where our partner in the micro
grid is able to demonstrate the value
that I bring as a utility to helping
them get that micro grid constructed
that's one example take another example
charging stations in many states a
utility is precluded from owning and
building charging infrastructure so if
you want to enhance EB penetration you
certainly need to have charging stations
it makes a lot of sense to me to have
the utility be a partner in building two
charging stations so we figured out a
way to get into this we said let's do
pilots let's demonstrate that we add
value and the concerns and others have
about our participation do not outweigh
the benefits that we bring to the table
those are just several examples of how
partnerships can be helpful but the
utilities participation those
partnerships can be constrained by the
regulatory process do you have to start
to bring the regulator's in as part of
the partnership is that one of the one
of the ways that we overcome I mean kind
of what you're leading to David is that
we have all this technology out there
but the rules of the game are creating
an impediment for us to make that
penetration into the market I mean how
are you guys starting to find ways to
overcome that either in kind of the
sensor space or utility or with clean
technology in particular I could see
that being an impediment yeah I think
for us in California I mean our
utilities were also precluded from
getting into the charging infrastructure
game and so they had to go in front of
the Public Utility Commission they had
to make their case SD Jeanie was just
approved last year to install 3500
charging stations within our region it's
part of their power your drive program
they're doing it interestingly and
they are trying to incentivize drivers
to charge when we have a lot of Sun we
produce a lot of solo at more solar
rooftop installations than any other
city in the country we've got to do
something with all that power during the
day and the utility through their power
your drive program is trying to
incentivize drivers to plug-in during
the day when we have an abundant amount
of solar resources but again getting the
approval to do that was a lengthy
process a costly process and in really
an ongoing process so there is that
regulator the regulatory challenge I
think everyone faces but just to touch
on if we're gonna talk kind of the dirty
stuff here you know I represent my
organization clean tech San Diego
represents about a hundred and twenty
companies or members most of which are
private sector companies those private
sector companies trying to work within
the boundaries of the university or the
city or the utility is quite challenging
the the universities the cities the
utilities have created very large
bureaucracies that are very challenging
for the private sector to work within so
that so I think that's a you know that's
not a regulatory thing it's a it's a
process II that that we need to real you
know we need to figure out if we're
going to really propel adoption of
technology a lot of these kind of
bureaucracies are not allowing for it
and that's something that we we have to
turn upside down in order to move this
forward I mean on that bureaucracy front
so we live in a time of incredible
opportunity for change this new
technology and what we can do at all all
this data is is amazing
there are lots of places for us to focus
our attention one of the things that is
so special about being in this room with
all of you is is that the level of
collaboration in in in Pittsburgh and
and with Carnegie Mellon and as a
community that you have because you are
rebuilding and because you are focused
is a bet that we as a private company
make on and taking a look around the
room to say are these people
collaborating effectively is it likely
that there's going to be a positive
outcome and you have something very
special here and I think really making
sure that you continue that forward
movement with
you know palpable progress is the thing
that is necessary to for companies that
are figuring out where my best Jason's
doing an amazing job in San Diego it's
it's it's easy to be in San Diego
because of the this very effective
organizations been put together it's
great to be here because of the level of
collaboration so the dirty secret from
our point of view is there's a limited
amount of bandwidth and you got to
figure out where you're gonna make your
investments and and I wouldn't encourage
you because this is a great place rich
maybe do you I mean on that with with
collaboration you guys have some really
key projects in the Duquesne Light
Service territory both in terms of smart
meters and micro grids I mean and you
guys have been partners on some of those
two with Itron I mean what what kind of
leads to that from your standpoint and
your perch is the CEO of Duquesne Light
in terms of making those decisions on
which projects to advance versus where
do I hold my gunpowder
yeah so we're trying to approach it
taking a what I would call a varied
portfolio approach so as we talked a
little bit about earlier there's some
regulatory constraints to go through
trying to get regulatory approval for
something that's new and evolving is a
very long process it involves a lot of
intervenors coming in that want to carve
out their space so one of the things
that we've done and we're approaching it
from the perspective of developing pilot
programs so we have an AV charging pilot
program that we're doing we have a micro
grid pilot program that we're doing them
when you approach it from a pilot
perspective it's not as fast as you
would like it to go but what you're
doing is you're teasing out you know all
of the other stakeholder interests and
where they may be coming from you're
teasing out regulatory challenges that
may be there you're teasing out the
technology challenges that may be there
so that you can kind of do a
proof-of-concept
and then accelerate through the process
and hopefully win broad stakeholder
support when you go in to ask for that
regulatory change other things that we
do you know we partner with the other
utilities in Pennsylvania you know we
all kind of have a kindred spirit of how
we view the industry and our vision of
where it's going so together you know
it's the voice of many so to speak where
we try to get legislation introduced to
knock down you know
some of the barriers that are there you
know we talked about some of the
regulatory impediments you know and we
talked a bit about gee I think grant you
are indicating you don't need to
replicate the infrastructure two and
three times right so you heard and
talked a little bit earlier about the
utility model the way the utilities earn
a return is you put plant in the ground
you earn a return on that investment at
the end of the day well when you think
about it you know when we talk about
smart cities and smart meters that are
out there Duquesne Light is deploying
you know a state-of-the-art
communication backbone that they gather
all of that data from the smart meters
that are out there really doesn't make a
lot of sense for the water company to
develop the same Network the gas utility
developed the same network using one
network you can kind of leverage that
investment once because we're all
serving the same stakeholders right but
when you look at other utilities under
that model its gee well if I buy that
service from Duquesne Light I can't earn
a return on it so there's ways to
overcome that we'd have to go to the
regulator and say look just because
we're buying a service from a utility
they should be allowed to earn some type
of synthetic return on that right this
way we're getting a much more efficient
you know deployment you know of capital
so I think those programs kind of you
know tease some of those things out and
it's it's going to be a slower process
then you would like when you're involved
you know with the regulated industry
part of its bureaucracy as you indicated
and I think we're working hard to knock
all of that down we certainly are
Duquesne Light but the regulatory
process really we need an increased
focus on the part of our regulators to
kind of up their game a bit and you know
start being streamlining the processes
so to speak but as we know there's a lot
of process involved you know so so maybe
to build on that a little bit in David
I'm gonna pivot to you here's you know
so regulations are put in place for a
reason right you know so that you're
trying to protect or or provide some
sort of continuity within a system and
one of the things that we talked about
earlier is these ideas of challenges you
know what are some of the challenges
that you guys see in your organization's
in terms of you know what's up ahead
what would kind of you know what are you
worrying about whether it's like cyber
threat or privacy data privacy issues
and
and how are you starting to organize or
marshal resources within your
organization's to kind of prepare
yourself for some of these these
challenges that lay on the horizon give
a solution first and I think rich said
in and others as well that this whole
notion of outreach and education or let
me say it differently collaboration so
one of the things that Edison Electric
Institute has been doing over the last
ten years
is pulling regulators together with
utility executives such as rich putting
them in a room and dealing with some
very tough issues and it's an
off-the-record conversation we have
members of the financial community there
too and we deal with these cutting-edge
issues so that the regulator's get an
understanding of how their regulations
can be an impediment to the evolution
and the adoption of technologies that
has worked but as rich said that is a
very very very slow process because
there are hundreds of regulators
throughout the United States
you can pull ten regulators in if you if
you multiply that it would take you 100
years so there's got to be a better
process so the regulators get together
three major times a year so what we've
tried to do at E is to have a session
with them a Saturday session they get
into town early we spring for lunch and
have a dialogue on some of these big big
issues let me tell you what some of the
big issues are and you really started
with one of them cybersecurity
so as we digitize the electric system
that's really what we're doing we're
making that electric system much smarter
much more accessible much more customer
driven it means that there's a lot of
information that is provided to the
utility and utility is the trusted
advisor with the customer utility
through that smart meter with ami has a
lot of information they see but now
there are a lot of other technologies
that are plug it into that grid a rich
mention it one essential platform aside
from a from a communication plan
form is the grid all of these
technologies feed into that grid and
that grid is being modernized it's being
upgraded it's being digitized so as you
seek to do that and you have all these
different devices all these different
devices
raise your cybersecurity risk
see at the transmission level there are
mandatory enforceable rules at the
distribution level they're not I'm not
advocating that you need them but I'm
just suggesting that there is an
increased risk that now begins to be
exposure to the utility utility wants to
be way out in front and wants to serve
the customer wants to customize the
services once you use the best
technology thing they can't can to deal
with resiliency and reliability and
affordability but they also acknowledge
that as they do that they're enhancing
their cybersecurity risk so there needs
to be some would say best practices
there's needs to be this recognition
that we need to deal with this evolving
challenge is this challenge bigger than
the adoption of the technologies I don't
know because we I'm not going to say no
system is perfect so that's one risk but
there's a second set of risks that are
there technology risk rich mentioned
that he said we don't necessarily take
on the technology risk with one gulp
what we do is we do pilots so there are
a lot of technology risks that are
associated with what we're talking about
and what the utility seeks to try to do
is share those risks with someone else
and the regulator doesn't understand
that because we have a cost-plus model
we make an investment we get a return on
it our pricing models got to change
we've got to incent behavior if you the
earlier panel spoke about charging
stations and the concentration of those
charging stations at the time where they
increase the demand on those substations
it means that you may have to increase
the capacity or you have to use a
different
for pricing structure and so we have to
make regulation understand that a
different pricing regime is very very
important but as they're moving to that
different pricing regime if I make it
too executive if I'm rich I want to make
sure I get my allowed return rich isn't
gonna want to put his return at stake
for an experiment on pricing so those
are the kinds of things that we have to
deal with rich I want to go to you on
this I'm gonna go into some of the
audience questions here I get this nifty
little tool that they gave me so I'm
gonna take advantage of it you know this
is from a consumer standpoint data
itself doesn't seem to be usage data
doesn't seem to be risky but I've been
picking it up maybe with some of the
things that Dave are saying like how do
you guys look at systemic risk it's a
real windy day out there today we know
Duquesne lights working hard the lights
are on right now things are great but
that's not always the case when you're
dealing with natural born threats or
others I mean can you talk a little bit
about how you guys are working to harden
the system and kind of reduce some of
these risks sure so there's a lot of
things that are going on so you have
kind of the physical risk to the system
and then you have the cyber risk to the
system so physically you know things
that we're doing there's a number of
things we do to harden the system the
hardened our substation so that could be
the infrastructure around the substation
to protect it from somebody trying to do
a bad thing to the substation we take a
look at the infrastructure of the how we
design our grid so that we have
redundancy built into the grid we have
two-way flows so to speak that we don't
have any radial feeds or we minimize the
radio feeds that are out there we have a
lot of technology that we deployed I
mentioned earlier we have thousands of
sensors in the field those are
controlled through our SCADA system in
our control room so a good example of
that is a lot of times when you see an
adage you may see your power go out for
a minute or so and then it comes back on
that's our control room that's looking
out there and seeing through the
technology we have where is that fault
located and then they're isolating the
system remotely so that a good example
that would be 30,000 customers are out
but we have
fault in one location they know where
they can isolate it from the rest of the
system bring the power back up within
minutes and now you've taken 30,000
customers down to within a minute down
to 5,000 customers are out ultimately
you have to roll a vehicle out there to
repair you know the woods out there but
that allows us really is significantly
you know reduce the outage time that's
out there so there's a number of
investments that we're making on the
asset side on the physical side and then
on a technology side on the cyber side
there's just a ton of investment that's
going on and partnerships with EEI and
other utilities the sharing of best
practices our operational system that's
out there that actually operates the
assets in the field and the technology
and a field is isolated from the outside
world so it doesn't connect to anything
else other than into our control room so
we isolate it that way as you start
looking at the proliferation of smart
meters and then the customer data and
things that come out of that we have to
look at that a bit differently because
there's desires for people to access
some of that information so when you
think about cyber security you know you
approach that from a number of different
ways you have multiple layers of Defense
for people trying to penetrate you you
kind of design your system like you
compartmentalize it like a ship right if
you have a rupture on a ship you close
doors inside it you isolate it so that
the ship doesn't go down we look at how
do we isolate and compartmentalize
different systems within the company
itself and then on top of that we need
to start thinking about from a cyber
perspective as we look at smart cities I
think that has to be approached by the
specific technology their specific
desires we need to do with that
technology in the field for example you
know when we take a look at deploying
all these sensors out there if that data
is coming in and we want to give people
access to it but they can't control or
do anything with it that's one layer of
security that you'll put around it if
you have control of it where you can
actually go out there and take that data
look at where traffic flows are now go
out and start switching traffic lights
and changing the sequence of it that's a
different level of control and
protection that has to go around that so
I think it's you know as you look at it
you want to try to compartmentalize it
and then apply the appropriate level of
risk mitigation in each of those per
tick
you know Jason and Phillip I mean you're
seeing it with kind of new startup
companies developing new technologies I
try and obviously been an established
company for a long time how how are you
guys looking at it both from kind of a
macro perspective but also are you doing
education with new companies who are
just creating the new whiz-bang gadget
in the clean tech sector
what's the both sides of that spectrum
look like so clean tech San Diego
launched the San Diego regional energy
innovation Network last year which is a
California energy committed acronym -
that is theirs which is a California
Energy Commission funded program to
support early-stage energy entrepreneurs
and help them get their product to
market the state of California is also
set aside about forty five million
dollars to invest in these companies so
if you have a start-up and you want to
bring it to San Diego let me know but
what we've done with that that that
program and probably the the biggest and
most important thing we've done is we've
brought the universe or that you know
the utility to the table we brought the
military to the table we've brought
these different entities to the table
that these companies are trying to help
solve their issues so they can hear
firsthand from SD GE these are some of
our internal and external threats that
we're trying to face from an energy
management perspective or distribution
perspective they can hear from the
military and talk about micro grids and
energy independence and what that means
and how their technology may be able to
fit into that so what we've done you
know we like pilot programs and pilot
projects in San Diego as well but you
know going back to this kind of notion
of collaboration when early-stage
companies can sit in a room and kind of
a neutral space with the utility with
the universities and others to talk
about their technology and kind of the
real-world application of that
technology there's significant benefit
in that and so I think these these types
of conversations not just happening here
on a stage but in a room with kind of
the next round of innovators is
increasingly important and we're using
those that ability to facilitate those
conversations and help in these
technology companies develop a
technology that actually has a market in
that market being around cyber energy
generation energy management whatever it
may be yeah it's like maybe I agree
all these comments but a slightly
different take which is that we feel
that we're on the issue security and
privacy actually better off supporting
industry standards and and not trying to
go it alone
so so you know we're working with best
minds and standards bodies in order to
establish a common set of standards and
ask our partners and startups to conform
to a series of privacy and cyber
security and communications and other
standards we need to make innovation
easy and predictable in order to really
stimulate it and so there when we talk
about platforms the rules have to be
published and then you have to have
third parties that can verify that the
rules are being enforced and so we have
a number of members in the audience from
do e as an example we've worked with the
defense labs on doing penetration
analysis on the standards that we've
used we're using standard technology
building blocks that have been proven in
other industries financial markets as an
example that have very high security
requirements in which we're able to
embed proven technology and some new
sensor applications but but this stuff
has been around for a long time so that
we're leveraging huge technology
investments local example Qualcomm in
San Diego you know spends billions of
dollars a year on our D when we have
cellular technology requirements we're
gonna we're going to draft off of the
investments that they've made so we're
collaborating on technology driving
standards and and using industry experts
in order to ensure that things have gone
properly thank you so there's this slide
of things starting to look like my email
feed so you guys are percolating a lot
of questions out there so I'm gonna make
sure that get to some of them here you
know in a you know one of the questions
from the audience here is about data
awareness and it may be picking up with
something Jason was saying here at the
Scott Institute in Carnegie Mellon you
guys are really building kind of the
pipeline of the next generation of
innovators that are gonna you know work
in companies like Duquesne Light and
clean tech San Diego and EEI and hITRON
can you talk a little bit about kind of
the role of the Institute intern
of kind of formulating this net
generation and not just tackling these
big issues but really creating the
technicians they're gonna fill in kind
of the the mindsets and build this next
generation of applications so the good
news is that we have about a hundred and
fifty faculty that are working in energy
related topics already and many of those
are collaborating and that's one of the
things that we're known at for here at
CMU is the level of sort of integration
and collaboration between our different
colleges so when people come to us and
they have a particular problem we
actually are able to pull the
researchers together to sort of tackle
issues we've done that a long time
particularly with the Metro 21 and the
deployment sort of the way that they've
handled that in the Scott Institute is
sort of looking at some of those things
as well it's like how can we be
preparing because we know even based on
what Ann said this morning you know it's
certainly not the the utility of the
past the the skill set needs to be
entirely different and so the fact that
we're strong in robotics and AI machine
learning and cyber is an incredibly
strong asset for a university like this
one so what I like the most about having
all of you here and thank you again for
coming to campus
is the opportunity to hear you say those
words because as much as we say that on
a you know day to day basis or within a
class or you know within our daily work
out in the community it's an important
thing to hear from you all that that's
what you're really looking for
could I just one super quick thing grant
sorry to break this paradigm that
suggested that there are sensors that
communicate that you collect that
information and then you analyze it
afterwards smart sensors are probably
going to be the future we're talking
about the next generation we have to
embed the intelligence out at the edge
of the network and have these devices
talking to each other we are not going
to control this new dynamic volatile
environment with one central brain we're
not going to jen is in seoul's model is
broken down on the generation side
central computing is broken down as a
way to control this network that's got
these dynamic generation devices on it
so by please think outside the box in
terms of the paradigm that you're using
in thinking about next generation
devices that that that they are smart
communicative safe and secure
economical and last a long time by the
way it's not an easy thing to build but
more intelligent interoperable all of
those things it's AI that's what's gonna
drive everything you can look at all the
improvements a lot of improvements have
been made in hardware technology the
next level of improvements are in
software technology believe me
tremendous improvements that are taking
place so so I got time for two more
questions here real quick you know the
one thing here you know one of the folks
in the audience was asking beyond pilots
where are some of the best strategies to
deploy technology you know this really
makes me think about some of the
challenges that we've seen in the city
is that we can get the pilots up and
running the challenge we have is going
to scale so what are some things that
you would kind of lend in a conversation
maybe you know a quick minute or so in
terms of how do you get the scale how do
we go beyond just the pilots so I would
say from the city of San Diego
perspective again going back to the
pilot that was a pilot with the street
lights and the sensors the city IQ
project that started as a pilot we're in
year 3 now and it's a full-scale project
I think the value of it's about 43
million so it started as a pilot and it
actually became something real I don't
know that that necessarily happens all
the time but I think what got it to
where it was to where it is today
is leadership from the city and a focus
of the city to get it to where it is
today but also the ability of and the
willingness of the private sector
company in this case current by GE to
work with the city to make sure that the
technology not only met the needs of the
city but also met the needs of their own
needs so I think it takes a champion on
both ends to push it to the end and
really see it be built to the extent
that it should be as opposed to just
remaining a small pilot program with a
few learnings it's public policy
leadership and we can give one good
example and I'm not an advocate for
saying you have to have mandatory
renewable portfolio standards but it
took a few regulators I might be but I
can't say that it took a few regulators
to say we need to move increasing
towards renewables you know what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna mandate it okay so
that was public policy leadership
okay it takes public policy leadership
and then on the other side it takes
someone with deep pockets so if you're
trying to move a technology forward very
rapidly you need to Bill Gates or
someone else that believes in that
technology is willing to take the risk
put up $2 and someone who also has very
significant political persuasion so I
got I go I got the the hook here but I
got one more question I think my mom was
in the audience actually is it the
question is how can energy utilities
become better partners with
municipalities who are working to
decrease sustainability and resilience
ie provide accessible data and
streetlights so I don't see my mom but
you know I mean we've had a great
relationship with Duquesne light but I
mean across the board where do you see
kind of where do these relationships
taking us in terms of the partnerships
between universities and utilities and
cities what's what's the blue sky look
for you ten seconds and seconds economic
vitality focus on the outcome don't get
hung up on the mechanics of how it's
going to happen when we come together to
build more sustainable livable and
successful cities it will knock down the
barriers that stand in the way of our
collaboration terrific I don't know that
I have anything else to add to that it's
perfect his bio is visionary that was
perfect and so I would just say that
that research and and partnerships with
universities can be a big part of that
so we look forward to continued
conversation and we welcome the folks in
the audience to be a part of that too
right thanks everyone thank you so much
this panel